Hey guys!
What would happen if you took transparent green slime
and dunked it into a container of liquid nitrogen?
You've been asking for it,
So today, I'm doing it,
We have a container of liquid nitrogen
Now we need some ninja turtle ooze
And you might remember a previous
video I showed you how to make it
All you need is some transparent school glue,
some yellow and green food coloring
and some borax.
Now to make our ninja turtle slime,
all you need to do is pour
a little bit of water into one bowl.
Doesn't have to be much, maybe just
half a cup or so.
And then pour a little bit more
water into a different container.
Same amount -
quarter to half a cup.
It doesn't really matter
Now we're going to take our
school glue
and we're going to empty the entire container
into the one with about half a cup of water
Then we're going to take some of our green food coloring
and add five drops of green,
two drops of yellow
and then go ahead and stir it all up
You want to keep stirring it until
it feels like the glue has blended in thoroughly with the water.
Kind of looks like green jello.
But you don't want to drink this stuff.
Now to our other container we're going to add
a little bit of borax
We're aiming
for about half to one tablespoon
but it doesn't have to be perfect.
If you end up using too much borax,
it won't dissolve
but it's not a big deal.
Just add a little more water until it does.
At this point, we add the two liquids together
and watch the magic happen.
Here we go
Just like that guys,
you can see instantly it starts globbing up
Look at that!
Just takes no time at all
we've got instant slime
This is why you don't have to worry about using too much water,
'cause all the slime just globs to itself
and you can pull it out and leave all the reside behind
It is amazing
how quickly that comes together.
Alright, at this point we can just
reach in and grab it!
Oh yeah, that's some good stuff. Look at that.
Oh man, that's perfect.
Transparent, green, gooey
ninja turtle ooze
Fishing for slime...
You can just let your slime sit in a cup for a couple minutes.
All the water will collect out
and you can just pour it off, and then you're just left with the gooey slime itself.
If you scoop this stuff in your hands,
you can see it comes out in, like, a nice, green glob
and it moves very very slowly
but over time it will, like, start to drip.
It's very cool stuff.
And it's non-toxic, so if you get any in your mouth
it's not really gonna do much harm
It just doesn't taste very good.
You can break it,
but then just give it a few seconds
and it just melds right back into itself again.
It's now time to take our liquid nitrogen,
put it in this container,
and then dunk the slime in it.
Aw, that's so cool!
It looks like, kinda foggy and cloudy,
and then when I blow it,
it just brightens right up.
And that green slime on those
black gloves looks amazing.
This slime has just been sitting here and
already you can see it's starting to get a little
bit crispy around the edges.
I say crispy, but it's actually
just freezing.
Alright, let's make it happen
Slime vs. liquid nitrogen.
Oh wow, it went through like a top layer of nitrogen there
I'm just gonna hold it here, and let it dip itself into the nitrogen
Oh, wow
That's cool.
*chill, science-y music*
Whoops, dropped it.
Well there's no going back now, is there?
So is this getting hard yet?
Yep, that's starting to freeze up.
That's really cool though, this part
right here is really spongey,
and still very slimy,
but yet right here is, like, frozen solid.
Wonder if I could actually pull that out now
Whoop, that's cold.
Oh, wow.
Look at that.
Look at that! *laughs*
This is the part that went into the nitrogen first
and you can see that actually is frozen solid now.
You know what this reminds me of,
is those little gummy frogs that you get
that are like white on the bottom and
gummy and green on the top?
So let's put this in,
and get the rest of it.
*chill music*
Man, look at all the vapor
It's still springy
it's still spongy here
which actually is really surprising.
When I pull this out, listen to it crackle.
*crackles*
Oof, it's a little cold to hang onto
and these breaking off in my hand here.
Look at this.
That's solid.
Look at that!
That's one of the first pieces that went-
whoops
That's like as hard as a rock.
It's kind of even got the slime texture to it.
That looks pretty neat.
Yeah, shatters, yeah...
Oh wait, wait! Look!
Inside here there's still a little
bit of slime that is not frozen.
That is weird!
Let's crack this stuff open and see
what's inside.
Let's give this a little tap.
Oh, that's harder than I thought.
Holy heck!
Alright.
Daaaang.
And look at that! Inside of there
it's still slime!
You can still dig it out.
So this is really interesting, guys.
We froze the slime in liquid nitrogen
for about a minute,
and I thought this thing was frozen completely solid,
and yet when we smash it open,
we have these slimy green bits that don't seem to be affected at all
This is very very peculiar.
It almost makes me feel like
the outside layer that's freezing
is forming an insulating barrier
preventing the cold to travel through to the middle.
I'm under the impression this might take a while to warm these things back up,
so I went and got my propane torch.
*whispers* Smoky!
That is nuts.
I can smell, like, burning slime.
What does that feel like?
It feels like taffy.
Alright, update guys.
This stuff is taking forever to thaw.
We've tried heating it with a blowtorch,
we've let it sit for half an hour
and it's starting to warm up
it's getting to kind of like this gummy stage,
but it's not thawing out.
So to speed the process, I tried
filling up a container with very very hot water.
Let's see if that makes a difference.
Oh wow, it floats.
Wasn't expecting that.
So that's super interesting, guys
If, uh, you put frozen slime
into warm water it will actually float
until the ice melts, and then it'll sink.
Ooh, it's nice and gooey.
That's fun.
So my nitrogen evaporated out of this
container but I still have this one left,
I was thinking if we dangle a piece of string down to the nitrogen,
Oh, wow, look at that!
You can like actually see the second it hits the vapor
Oh, man, that is really cool.
Slime is awesome!
Play with it!
Do it!
Sweet!
That's one of the strands that we just left in,
It looks like it broke -
oh, wow, listen to that.
*clinks*
That actually sounds like glass.
If you put this in your hands, can you squish it?
*crunch noises*
Oop! It went down my shirt.
Now just for fun, I whipped up a few more colors of slime
to make rainbow slime,
and wondered what these would look like once they're dipped in liquid nitrogen?
Here we go
I'm feeling it
Oh, look at that!
Like, the instant it touches the top of that fog,
it just starts vaping like crazy,
That's cool. That's cool!
And we're about to make contact.
There we go.
That's so cool! Look at how that's all blended into a nice rainbow color
So you can see this is all still really slimy.
Down here starts getting a little rubbery.
Let's go ahead and pull the whole thing out
and see how the entire piece looks.
Wow!
Okay, that's kind of cool.
Look at the colors!
So it's gone from being, like, super shiny
and glossy to almost looking like frozen chocolate.
These colors have really firmed up and gone opaque.
You can see the way, like, it just started freezing as it was sitting in the cup there.
This stuff here is still really slimy,
and then there's a transition point where it gets really rubbery.
It's like the consistency of a rubber tire.
But then everything after that just gets extremely brittle.
It just shatters.
Tell me that doesn't look cool.
Oh, yeah!
Check that out, that is awesome!
It's like a giant rainbow tongue.
So I've still got a little bit of my rainbow slime left over
and a little bit of liquid nitrogen,
so I'm just going to ball this stuff up
and throw it all in there at the same time.
Let's do the drop!
Three
Two
One
What do you say we just give this like,
thirty-five, forty seconds to soak and then pull it out and take a look?
It's already hard on the outer layer.
I'm gonna see if I can grab it with my hands.
Whoo!
Sweet
Looks like a big Play-doh turd...
If we crack it open, oh look it's still got a gummy, slimy interior.
It just froze on the outer layers here,
but it's still, like, super gummy on the inside.
Mmm, it's chewy.
It's too bad, something that looks this good should be edible.
Let's put this one in.
Oh, I love that
Like, the second it hits the top layer it just starts vaping like crazy.
Sounds like popcorn popping.
Look at the way it cracks, like the more it freezes the more it cracks
right down the center.
It looks like it's frozen solid.
Oh, nope, there's still a little bit of gummy there in the middle.
Look at that.
Oh, just like that one little piece, that's all there is.
Now over time these chunks will warm back up
and turn back into that gooey slime,
but it's going to take a couple of hours at these temperatures.
So there you have it, guys.
That's what happens when you put slime in liquid nitrogen.
So thanks again to Muskaan Sanya for the request,
and if any of you have cool ideas for experiments you want to see me do,
just leave them down in the comments below.
Thanks for joining me for this experiment! I'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.
Can't tell you how many times we've cleaned this workbench this week.
Hey guys, thanks for watching, and remember I'm giving away prizes now on every new video.
All you have to do to qualify is
subscribe to my channel, ring the bell, and select to be notified when my next videos get released.
The secret link to my giveaways will be pinned in the comments for the first twelve hours.
If you like what I'm doing, show your support right now by giving this video a big thumbs up
and share with a friend.
I love you back, and I'll see you next time.